die entwicklung der personal computer
ist den letzten 20 jahren wirklich
gigantisch verlaufen jetzt können wir
den nächsten schritt machen der zu einem
ähnlichen entwicklungsverlauf führen
wird woran forscher derzeit in diesem
bereich arbeiten jetzt bei pixum science
fiction im fachmagazin nature physics
wurde über einen noch in den
kinderschuhen steckende technik
berichtet die sogenannte magno nick mit
magnetischen wellen soll es möglich sein
informationen zu übertragen
diese wellen werden dann als madonnen
bezeichnet doch wie entstehen sie
elektronen die parallel zueinander
stehen sind in magnetischen bauteilen zu
finden
wenn sich dann der elektronen um die
eigene achse drehen einen spin bekommen
verbreitet sich dann auch ein impuls an
die umliegenden elektronen die spin
welle bewegt sich dann durch das ganze
bauteile
doch was ist dann ein mann ein mann dann
ist eine spin welle der eine
quanteninformation mitgegeben wurde in
der magnetik verbirgt sich aber noch
eine ganz spezielle eigenschaft da die
elektronen auf ihrem platz bleiben
stoßen sie nirgendwo an und erzeugen
somit kaum wärme so roboter die ruine
von der universität utrecht wo wir
gerade bei wärme sind kommen wir auch
schon direkt zu den herkömmlichen
elektronischen rechen geräten viel
leistung benötigt aktuell auch immer
noch eine starke kühlung aber warum
in herkömmlichen rechenmaschinen
arbeiten zwar auch elektronen aber auf
eine ganz andere weise in einem computer
sind keine magnetischen bauteile
eingebaut die leistung erzeugen die
elektronen also der spin der elektronen
der spielt überhaupt keine rolle
die elektronen fließen durch die leitung
dabei entstehen dann keine wellen
sondern ströme elektrische ströme auf
dem weg durch beispielsweise ein rechen
element eines pcs kollidieren die
elektronen dabei allerdings ständig mit
atom bei dem zusammenstoß wird energie
frei und wo energie freigesetzt wird
entsteht auch eine neue energie und zwar
ihr wärme dieser wärme wird dann mit
lüftern und anderen kühlelementen die
beispielsweise einer wasserkühlung die
stirn geboten
da das nicht immer ausreichend klappt
muss häufig mit einem doch sehr
beachtlichen verschleiß gerechnet werden
rechnen können die elemente dann oft
nicht mehr richtig früher war das aber
noch viel schlimmer
noch vor 69 jahren musste für einen
computer ein ganzer raum eingerichtet
werden dementsprechend war damals auch
die kühlung ein ganzes stück anders aus
am beispiel der elektronik numerical
integrierten computer projekt aus dem
jahr 46 entwickelt wurde er von und für
das militär eigentlich sollte er
flugbahnen von geschoßen berechnen da
aber die fertigstellung etwas zu lang
gedauert hat wurde er dann benutzt um
die folgen einer wasserstoff
bombenexplosion auszurechnen
das benötigte dementsprechend leistung
und wurde dementsprechend war der
rechner war so groß dass der ganze raum
in dem er stand gekühlt werden musste
und das war gar nicht so leicht der 27
tonnen schwerer und 170 quadratmeter
einnehmende rechner besaß 17 1468
vakuumröhren und dioden und die wurden
ziemlich warm
wer mit dem ähnlich arbeiten musste
konnte sich also auf ein warmes
raumklima einstellen und der verschleiß
der röhren der war ziemlich groß jede
woche gab es mehrere stunden ausfall in
dem dann die kaputten röhren ersetzt
werden mussten
wenn man honig unserer elektrogerät
revolutioniert müssen wir uns weder auf
ein warmes raumklima noch auf eine warme
hosentasche einstellen
wir kennen das ja vom smartphone läuft
darauf eine rechenintensive app wird das
gerät so richtig schön war es gibt ja
die genannte kollision zwischen
elektronen und atomen die magno nick
kann aber noch viel mehr die leistung
könnte enorm gesteigert werden dazu
müssten die spin wellen nur so
ausgerichtet werden dass sie sich
verstärken
die hersteller von computerchips
arbeiten immer häufiger am limit alles
muss kleiner werden und das auch noch
bei tausenden und millionen von eh schon
sehr winzigen drähten und verbindung auf
den chips in der magnet muss dagegen
nichts verdrahtet werden induktion
erledigt den job der lästigen drehte
einer der beachtlichen punkte ist jedoch
die leistung die mit der magnettechnik
erreicht werden kann
zitat ihre taktfrequenz die bei
halbleitern nun schon seit zehn jahren
bei rund 3 gigahertz liegt könnte mit
nun auf das jetzt kommt 1000 fache
ansteigen zitat ende das jetzt kommt
zwar von mir so der ukrainische
wissenschaftler andere schuhmarkt vom
optimus zentrum
so trist durch diese ganze technik
klingt so futuristisch ist sie
eigentlich gar nicht dieses jahr auf der
cebit konnten die ersten entwicklungen
ausgestellt werden forscher der
technischen universität kaiserslautern
unter anderem burkhard hillebrand haben
einen magnetischen transistor mit auf
die messe gebracht
das wohl auszuschließen ist von heute
auf morgen alle geräte auf eine
magnetische technologie umzustellen
kümmern sich die forscher schon jetzt
darum eine zwischenstation einzurichten
mit dieser könnten hersteller nach und
nach umrüsten
wie lange das ganze noch dauern wird das
ist ungewiss die technik steckt halt
noch in den kinderschuhen wir wissen
noch nicht auf welcher hürden die
entwickler noch stoßen werden
die geschwindigkeit mal fünf die steckt
gar nicht mehr in den kinderschuhen mehr
dazu erfahrt ihr hier oben im video mit
schallgeschwindigkeit also hier oben ist
im kommen alle links übrigens auch wie
immer unten in der video beschreibung zu
rap und zum block kommt er hier unten
und hat mich eure meinung zur magno nick
denkt er das ist eine technologie ist
die noch keine verwendung finden wird
oder glaubt ihr dass sie so bald sie
einsatzfähig ist auch großen nutzen
bringen wird diskutiert darüber wie
immer in den kommentaren und ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran